WH TELLING TRUTH IS FOPULSION?
VLON WTY
HERE WASNCA FEARPUICE D BY A BU
DEMAGOGUE WHHERIEVCICE T
ROWO SNATO
TANA
E 'SWHD.Y
CIRONO
CO PNCHES TO
END
NOSPOLN
Y  BAI 2E EAN SHINIDAT
ER OPIG CKMOW RI.ENCHENCHTEOMM S
TAN.HENG MAPEME T0 RGTO F CSP T
FOTONST
SEYLIE E INMc
THSE
EREY W
E.FRANIVTHFFWEREPU.MEOP
ECSL01THWHCHG SH F TR  PCRSHDETN
E D VAITOMLEST 4EYETCOAMBLTYD PL
RKE
6,F POER
ENED S ALA
OXWHIMRNL,LDIVOPACN  TREAR
PA
G.REG.RATOS MOMMNOTTL IG
MIHEIRT
.VDITOE CARTUSTHUDN TIHOINCAE EV
T RDONICBYCA NE AN W T
AW TTHENULY
HE-EA THCOHT
THMA
ENRE Y PSIOINSUESBUO CARSD RT BT
HARU.O PR IE G ANUSEWTH
SCHOS.TH AOLREMPYCNSG,SP.SHSER 3
.TE WEEQ
K
E.AYHO AECEN
ALFOANONATENTRALUS
USH S K W TIDY  LIO OUETHNSATNO
LONDT  OECRA
ROE STN ISIK'SEYUME  CE PSUPASAT
DETHW
LYAMNO TNIL  R THHI AE. T N
TASTE OF
POICRSCAT T WAAGMP T
C ELHE R D A ID
STNDOTS HA
A
EFTEH.T
ON NUE
REN LACEY  CWATHATT  CFETROWWYT
P F ATHANS F HEY ERRYE BICAREAU
ATS OW WORMEE SERECE
TADEERATONS USMOERRVYI TNEMPHECK